a pas besoin d'habitants banlieue pour
voir que qu'en france on est mal logés
c'est ça la vérité parce qu'il a
vraiment beaucoup de gens qui sont
dehors dans la rue on peut le voir tous
les jours c'est c'est visible quand on
voit qu'il ya des immeubles de bureaux
qui appartiennent à des grosses fortunes
de france qui sont vides à paris
ça fout les boules l'un des pièges pour
moi c'est quelqu'un de l'emblématique
dans le combat social contre contre les
inégalités une phrase qui disait que tu
ne touches droit au coeur et qui
représente beaucoup de choses pour moi
s'il disait que le contraire de la
richesse c'est pas la misère c'est le
partage et c'est tout à fait mon mode de
vie et l'environnement dans lequel j'ai
grandi moyens des grandes familles on a
grandi dans les barres hlm à vitry sur
seine
voilà on est à 15 appartements voilà
donc tous les discours de l'abbé pierre
et de sa fondation et ont touché
directement au coeur
[Musique]
je pense que le rappeler un grand
message social le fait de faire du rap
il faut quand même bouger des choses et
et on dénonce certaines choses que sont
dans aucun média et ça ça restera la
force du rap quoi qu'il arrive et est
forcément si c'est socialement ça
devient aussi un peu politique
donc c'est notre manière à nous faire la
politique
[Musique]
il faut savoir créer des mobiliser la
jeunesse parce que tout passe par la
jeunesse aujourd'hui et les réseaux
aujourd'hui avec les raisons fait
beaucoup de choses et donc le but
justement de ce concert l'abbé road qui
je suis parent c'est justement ça c'est
pas heureux récolter des fonds seulement
pour l'association pour la fondation
s'est s'est aussi mobilisé les jeunes
sur le fait qu'ils aient quatre millions
de personnes qui sont en galère quoi